je ne comprends pas qu'on ne fasse pas
confiance à la nouvelle génération
j'ai confiance de nouvelle génération
peut-être parce que je la connais que je
la fréquente depuis très longtemps que
j'ai toujours eu ce souci d'aller vers l
de l'écouté de lui parler que mes quatre
enfants qui sont donc de quatre classes
d'âge différents moments toujours voilà
emmener des camarades
donc voilà j'ai toujours été en contact
j'ai vu j'ai vu grandir cette jeunesse
donc je perçois je perçois le potentiel
qui porte en elle
je perçois toutes ses capacités qui sont
encore à éclore et je perçois aussi la
nécessité de lui dire de lui dire de lui
dire deux choses essentielles
la première série capable elle est
capable donc oui j'ai confiance en elle
elle est capable
la deuxième c'est qu'il n'est pas
miraculeuse elle peut faire d'énormes
bêtises et que en son sein il ya aussi
des jeunes des jeunes qui ont l'esprit
rétrograde
voilà qui sont des des vieux machin qui
ne sont pas curieux des autres qui n'ont
pas le goût du risque qui n'ont pas
l'envi l'envi l' envie de vivre envie de
transformer donc il ya tout ça en la
jeunesse mans peut lui faire confiance à
leur demande d'être exigeant exigeant
vis-à-vis de ce lg de ceux qui avant
deux ans pris les décisions et en fait
que le monde est tel qu'il est exigeant
vis-à-vis de ceux qui ont fait que le
monde est beau mais aussi de ceux qui
ont fait que le monde et violent que le
monde est injuste que le monde est
insupportable pour certains parce que ce
monde n'est pas donné
chaque génération peu le pétrir le
modelé comme elle l'entend comme elle le
rêve comme elle le veut il ya quelques
valeurs fondamentales on les transmet
eux ils doivent les faire vivre le droit
lui même le droit et la matière la plus
vivante que je connaisse
même si on a l'impression que les règles
et les lois sont figés
non le droit est la matière la plus
vivante que je connaisse pour la simple
raison que le droit c'est l'ensemble de
nos règles
vie commune exigeant vis-à-vis dans d
autres et exigeant vis-à-vis d'eux-mêmes
ne pas se contenter de juger mais pas se
contenter de de consommer de recevoir
des rites et exigeant vis-à-vis d'eux
mêmes c'est à dire chercher profondément
en eux ce qu'il ya de meilleur même si
ce meilleur est encore assoupie aller le
chercher l'arraché ce meilleur le jeter
au soleil à l'appui de façon à ce qu'ils
prospèrent qui donne de blake de belles
fleurs